hello and hillary and hello  it is a really mild start but you're  right alex we're dropping the  temperatures down just a couple degrees  this is still above normal we've got  this beautiful view from the strat  looking up to the north obviously the  circuit there but there's the plaza city  hall let's get the official temperature  up here for you  at mccarran airport we have just dropped  under 60 so  58 degrees that's 10 degrees cooler than  we were 24 hours ago saw some breezes  going on yesterday we'll check your  neighborhoods here  but the bottom line is high pressure is  beginning to settle in let's get you  hour by hour  we will be back to the low 60s by 8  maybe the mid 70s at noon  80 at 3 we're going for a high of 84  this afternoon which would put us above  normal  and the weather headlines real easy  we're going to be mild  not wild the ride on the temperature  roller coaster is easy and it's going to  be a very nice weekend we got it all  coming up in the 8 day forecast